thank you very much oh hey thank you
very much for for coming and first
before I start I want to send a deep
deep thanks to the organizers of this
workshop for preparing and educating
this audience I really loved the you
know series of talks so now I assume you
guys know a lot about what fhe is you
know a little bit about a delegation you
know why I oh so this is fantastic so we
can actually you know have some fun okay
so well yes I'm gonna talk about the
problem of delegating computation it has
been one of my obsessions in life still
is so let me tell you a little bit about
it so thank you so much horrible for the
fantastic talk you gave before me so you
presented the problem already which is
great so just a quick quick recap so
right we have the way we do computations
today is shifting now most of many of
our computation is done elsewhere and
some cloud not only our computation
actually you know we store our memory in
the cloud we do our computations
elsewhere and of course this raises a
lot of issues for us as cryptographers I
think the two main issues we we
considered is the obvious one is privacy
so we don't want the cloud to learn
information about our secret or secret
data or our secret computation sensitive
computation but it's on set another
seriously very fundamental issues that
of integrity how do we know that the
cloud is doing the computation correctly
and notice oh this is gonna be the focus
of the talk is an integrity I want to
proof that the cloud did its computation
correctly so even though one the Simon
Institute which is for a theoretical
computer science I don't really feel
like I have to motivate this problem but
so you know I will so I mean I thought
about this motivation flow because you
can say why do we care about proofs of
security you know we give them all our
data or competition to Amazon
don't you trust Amazon so uh you know
most of us make me trust Amazon but
there's still issues around how do we
know they were actually talking to
Amazon okay maybe we're not we think
we'll talk times on but we're talking to
some adversary's well I think in general
to make it kind of wildly used people
will be more secured if they knew they
could get a proof of security if proof
of correctness if they wished to so you
don't need to use the gas for proof each
time but it's nice to know that you
could press a button get a proof if you
wanted to okay so this is gonna be the
focus of this talk and note that the
interesting thing about integrity it's
not cryptography here
okay I'm not interested in secrecy now I
just won't crack this it's not a priori
it's not clear that it's any opto
graphic problem even okay but as we'll
see cryptography is used to solve this
problem even again even though I want to
stress again secrecy is not my concern
here okay so this is kind of you know
the classical problem that we're
interested in this is exactly what one
had so here's a client he wants to
compute some function f and an input
which he knows ok yes a function f and
input X he wants to do this computation
he doesn't have the resources to do it
so he asks the cloud to do it the cloud
computes the function for him so he
computes f of X but this cloud may be
malicious so he does not trust the Scud
or he does not know that he's talking to
the actual cloud he's thinking he thinks
he's talking to and so he wants a proof
of correctness proof that the
computation was done correctly and here
are the two important things that we
want from the proof okay we won first
that verifying should be easy much much
easier than doing the computation itself
okay so how is he think about it
essentially the size of the input and
the program think of the program is a
Turing machine so it's constant size so
it's essentially the size of the input
not more and in a minute I'll address
Stiles question from last time so this
is kind of you know the best you can
hope for so he has his input
the function but he shouldn't his
runtime should not depend on the runtime
of the computation and how about the
cloud the prover well he needs to do the
computation so tff is the time it takes
to compute this function and input X so
he needs to do the computation and so he
needs to run in time T of F which is the
time to do the computation but ideally
not more than that not much more than
that
yes joy many more than a single as long
as it doesn't go so I think ok so the
results we have work for this heading as
well so it's not important that it's a
let me think about it no it is important
actually sorry I take it back it is
important so what you're suggesting what
you're asking the question you're asking
is what if it's an NP question right so
what if there are many answers so for n
if the question of delegation if it's a
deterministic function on a
deterministic function changes
completely so that's one answer another
but what you're saying is actually not
quite the same as NP because you're
saying there are many the answer is not
always one if there is a witness and
zero if there's not only a witness there
just may be many accepting answers
giving you the answer one answer and you
look the language if you're taking off
you say X comma Y whether they're you
know it's a valid a it's in the relation
so if you can do deterministically than
you right so if if the answer is
something that you can deterministically
are compute from there then then it's a
P then it's the same short exactly very
interesting I didn't think about it but
I will it's very interesting so please
ask it's good one so to the researcher
okay so I don't know it's a very good
question
Hey okay so this is kind of the standard
setting okay but actually going back to
tars question from a1 stock this is not
necessarily the most realistic setting
so as we said we're not just delegating
computation and input X that we know
we're delegating our memory so you know
we're giving the counter entire memory
and we're asking the cloud to do the
computation so we're giving him our data
this data may be huge okay we can't even
store the data
so think of the case setting maybe a
more realistic setting is the setting
where we give the cloud our entire data
all our email we give Gmail our email
and we get something maybe some
certificate of our data some small
commitment or some small hash of our
data and now we ask the cloud to compute
thus far as some functions and my data
but all I had is some short certificate
or some shortcoming min of this data and
even in this context I want to be able
to get the result f of X and a proof of
correctness and note here that I also
had a commitment prime to be even more
general I may even want the the cloud to
do computation that may affect my data
maybe I want him to update things in my
data delete things in my data so this
now changes the commitment I have for my
data so this function may actually
change my data in which case I want him
to give me a new commitment to my data
and still I want to be able to have my
guarantees that verify I can verify very
efficiently and the cloud doesn't need
to have much overhead so let me be a
little more specific what's ideally our
go
so our goal is that the verification
time should not depend on this huge data
nor on the computation time okay by the
way the setting to think here of here is
you can think of the data is huge and
actually the runtime of F is smaller so
it's a different setting than the
traditional delegation setting so you
can think of F is really huge in the
function you computed some kind of you
know Ram program of this memory okay so
I do I want the verification time to
depend only on some security parameter
so it won't the stock security
parameters kind of hide inside this ol
but the all what does not mean constant
time it means essentially time that does
not depend on the data and the function
only depends on the security parameter
okay so the verification time should be
independent of the data and the function
and the time to prove so what the time
to prove so now actually it's important
in this setting where the data is huge
it's I want the time to be I want to
think of F now the function that I
compute as a ram machine a random access
machine and in this context it actually
it if you use a Turing machine or a ram
machine it's very different because if
you think of the data is being really
huge there can actually be an
exponential gap between the two okay
think of binary search okay the rare
machine works in log time whereas if you
think of it as a two machine it's linear
time okay so when I have huge amount of
memory I want to think of this function
as a ram machine and I want the prover
to run not much more at the time not
much more than the time the RAM machine
would run so really that I want the
overhead could be only depending on this
some security parameter that's my bush
so okay so most of the talk I'm going to
talk about actually the the classical
setting of delegation but let me but
since I talked about it so much by now
hey let me start with something new
fresh to make to keep me I'm just
excited so why I want to present a new
theorem which is joint work with the oh
man on a planet where what we do is we
construct a to message delegation scheme
a for for any ramp computations with the
essentially the properties I promised
you so verifying does not is independent
the time to verify does not depend on
the data or the complexity of the
function and it only depends on the
description of the function but I think
of it as constant and poopers runtime is
not much more than the runtime of the of
the Ram machine and this is under lwe
assumption learning with there and thank
you a Vinod for for not having I don't
need to talk more about this okay and
let me mention that there's been a bunch
of works that solved okay now I need to
be careful cuz I don't really understand
this really didn't work that well but
feel free to I'll blame the authors but
I think I think that there's related
work that showed how to achieve this
from IO but a selective version of this
I think where I think the meaning of
selective is that you get security from
IO assuming that all the functions you
want to compute are chosen before the
before the memory is get like a priori
fixed or chosen independently above the
memory yes just interrogation the aisle
Justin also got privacy I thought I
don't okay so you can't really get
privacy and expect them to the running
time I'm not really sure how because you
can't expect to have privacy and you
know know
anytime I'm okay yeah maybe some
pre-processing yeah okay let's continue
okay so way okay so let's start the with
the history of this problem so there's
been a lot a lot of work really nice
work
I apologize because I know I'm gonna
mess up and that reference important
works but sorry okay so the problem
we're going to focus on for the until
essentially the end of this the two
hours most of the time we're going to
focus and the classical setting okay
we're in this heading we think of X as
small and the runtime of F as big okay
and we allow the client to run in time
or the verifier on time linear or quasi
linear in the input size in terms the
end of the talk I'm gonna show you how
to get the RAM setting or the memory
setting okay so let's start so we want
to prove how do we get a proof so you
know when you start thinking about this
problem you know okay what do we have
you know what can we use and the first
thing that comes to mind is let's use
interactive force we have interactive
probes this is great so have the you
know the cloud gives us an interactive
proofs that he did the computation
correctly so you know thankfully we have
this notion which was studied in the
context of zero knowledge so we studied
for a secrecy actually but it has
nothing to do with the secrecy it's just
you know proof of validity and we have
beautiful works that show the power of
interactive course we know that you can
compute any piece based language using
an interactive proof okay more precisely
what we know is any language you can
give an inductive proof but the
verifiers runtime depends on the space
something like linear in the space okay
so we can use that to do linear space
computations this is great however in
this work they weren't interested the
focus was not on the provers runtime and
the verifies runtime is is essentially
the space but the poor's runtime
it's quite awful it's too - the space
squared more or less so there's the
cloud needs to work a lot in order to do
such a computation okay so this is not
good for us we don't want that a lot of
overhead for the cloud in order to give
us the proof okay so we several years
ago it was long time so with a Shafi and
Gauri we constructed we tried to make
this interactive proof efficient where
the prover runs time is proportional to
the actions the time to do the
computation but and we did it but only
for load that circuit in other words we
looked at the function we thought of it
at a circuit okay and now the time of
the verify the random of the verifier
dependent grew linearly with the depth
of the circuit okay so it's efficient
for low depth circuits for NC one for
example okay but for very non parallel
computation this is not a good solution
and let me actually stop here and
mention one of open problem that I've
really been obsessed with and I be
grateful if someone solves it $100 $100
guy will you split it with me
please do please do so uh okay so here's
what's open problem so we got the so
with interactive before you can to do
you can't hope that the verify I will
run less than the space because we know
from IP equals P space that you can't do
more than that but can you have the
verify run from time proportional to the
space and the prove ur proportional to
the time why does he told us and one
times two to the x squared okay so I
want the poober to be efficient polity
okay verify Paul yes so this is an open
problem please solve it we know how to
do it so I want to interactive proof of
the prover is efficient
okay so there's only polynomial overhead
we know how to do it but only for
languages that can be represented or
four functions sorry for function that
can be represented by shallow circuits
so the runtime of the verify depends on
the depth we would like to do it where
the random of the verifier depend on the
space so i know that he has to depend in
the space there's nothing I can do i
pico speed space so the verified runtime
will be proportional to the space I
can't do but I can't hope to do better
but I want the provers runtime to be
polity and not to to the space yes so
this is for good so this is first it
note that here when I say proof it's a
statistical soundness so even in all
powerful prover cannot cheat that the
notion of boosts next we'll go to
arguments so and that's what's coming up
next
okay so most of the focus of work in
this area almost all the focus has been
and trying to get so the previous
solution I showed you was very
interactive oh and there's a mobile it
has to be interactive in some sense okay
so with interactive proof in in the
solution with gancho free the number of
rounds was linear in the depth okay and
and any kind of solution will be for
general general solution will have a lot
of runs of interaction so the focus tone
of the in the literature was I'm trying
to get
no interaction or just to message you
back and forth so the client asks gives
them the computation maybe ask some
questions and gets back a proof that's
it
to message okay that's what people
wanted and they wanted arbitrary
computations okay so not not only load
up and not only pspace they want any
computation anytime to computation I
want proof so that has been the focus
and and if you want to do that you
cannot hope to have statistical
soundness so do
proofs and you have to move to the
regime of what's called arguments so now
one if you want are Bo you want to prove
correctness of arbitrary computation you
have to settle for computationally sound
proofs which means that an all-powerful
Cloud or prover can cheat but as long as
he cannot break lwe assumption or IO or
whatever it is
he cannot cheat okay so the assumption
is that this cloud cannot break some
cryptographic assumption that we're
using
okay so Vinod asked for landscapes I'd
enjoy
so uh okay
so I'll try to summarize the work that
has been done and this topic there's
been a lot of work and a lot of the
works I'm not gonna mention so I'm kind
of choosing a little you know few works
that have kind of mainly the theoretical
work I'm focusing on here I'm not
focusing on the more practical work so
there's been a lot of really nice
practical if they're not gonna mention
hey okay so the landscape so where did
this all start so it started with the
work from ninety-two of Killian where he
showed how to do it how to do the
legations came with four messages okay
so for mister division the only thing he
needed to assume is close resistant hash
function great solved for four message
that's all we need okay so four message
client send the message get back some
hash kind sense queries get back answer
that's it and then started the obsession
of getting this with two messages okay
so just question answer here's what's
know what is the low mountains around
complexity is it like yeah so look you
know that it depends on the ends and s
and the space so that's so if you have
space s you knew the number of rounds
you need depends on us that's the number
of rounds you know your northumberland
you can't do more than after mulling so
that's uh I mean lower bound I mean us
under complex assuming the phenomena
hierarchy does not collapse and so on
it's not really uh ok so Nick any other
questions so me kindly in 94 concern he
followed up so what he did he did to
message allocation or you can think of
it actually as one message even in the
random or Kamau
okay so essentially applied what's
called the first remiel paradigm if for
those of you are familiar for those who
not don't worry he applied this paradigm
in the work of Killian he got
essentially a one message in the random
Oracle model
to message were the first in some random
hash BCP there's only polynomial
overhead actually they have become quasi
linear PCBs yes
you know the depends you can do it in a
way that's quasi linear but yeah
actually in this slide I'm gonna show
you works that run time most of the work
the focus was not on getting the why the
linear but you know just polynomial
overheads from both sides but you wanted
the client to run in time that depends
only on the input independent the run
time but not necessarily linear in the
input and the clown should depend the
overhead should be only polynomial in
its run time not necessarily quasi
linear okay but but here actually was
pretty good the run time I mean you can
make it pretty good with with new PCBs
and that's all we could do for for a
while
oh so together with with Han we managed
to kind of squash the protocol the G
care protocol the protocol with gancho
fee and to make it to message so we get
to message delegation but again it's for
that the circuit and what we needed to
assume is computational peer which I
don't define think of fhe okay so those
who don't want to don't know what peer
is just think of fhe so okay good so
what what we do is delegations came for
any circuit so take your function think
of it as a circuit suppose the depth of
the circuit is d the verifier runs in
time d okay
so for shallow computations frankly one
type of computations is great for very
deep computation or competition that
cannot be parallelized efficiently you
know it's it's bad okay and that's it
that's all we knew for a while there
have been some works in the in the
pre-processing model so the
pre-processing model
and see or it's 4nc or more generally
you can think of like linear depths but
the thing grows with the depth
yes actually can kinda 4np not even 4p
I'm gonna mention that but yes exactly
yes
with these work you can also do
non-deterministic computations here
we're stuck with the terminus the
computations and then there was some
attempt a lot of really nice work trying
to do a delegation assuming
pre-processing so what is pre-processing
the thing you know what the client maybe
once will work hard and keep some some
secret or some state or something and
then he can he'll will never work hard
again ok so that was the way people
relaxed the model and there's been
really nice work starting with the novel
gentry and panel very nice work doing to
message delegation assuming fhe for any
deterministic computation okay
there was a slight negative in this in
this work and this the follow-up words
mentioned about which is there was this
rejection problem what is the rejection
problem the problem was that once the
the cloud in you that the client
rejected his computation he learned
something about his about the secret
state of the client and then he could
cheat so that it's ok as long as it calm
never rejects you
but once the client what as long as you
don't reject the computation that proof
but once you start rejecting the proof
you need to do the the pre-processing
all over again so that was a slight
negative and then there's work trying to
get around this you know they don't want
this residue you want one thing for
totally processing and that's it and
then there was a really nice work of
panic over and they've known that it was
also the pre-processing but here's their
work work was publicly verifiable so
public an affirmative
everybody knew if you rejected there was
known this rejection problem went away
okay because you don't you don't need to
keep state everybody can check whether
you're verified or not it's not it can
check whether you you accepted the proof
or not and this problem goes away and
they all they need to assume was was a B
attribute based encryption which a
standard assumption we know how to
under lwe unfortunately we know how to
do it under all w/e only for again
bounded depth so you need to say ahead
of time what the depth is and the verify
run times depends with the depth so
saying Jamie she was here but the good
thing about this work is that it's
publicly verifiable and let me just
mention these two works up here also
publicly profile these are not and then
there were really nice works trying to
to get public verifiable delegation for
any language actually their works was
for even non-deterministic languages
okay but they needed to rely on an
acknowledged assumptions okay and again
I want to mention the so this work was
for non deterministic languages the
works up they were for non-domestic
languages the westward for deterministic
languages okay so when the
pre-processing we can do you know
there's a rejection problem here which
kind of sucks if you come up with better
or a B schemes we can you know do
arbitrary and then if you're willing to
some knowledge you're golden you can do
anything
pre-processing okay you know just assume
that the market analysis and this is
these are much more I mean it's what
they were quite pre-processing which is
worse
he didn't need a news pre-processing so
this this is worse another hand random
Oracle model is well people that didn't
want to think of it as much better than
random Oracle so don't say that
hey I know get in trouble yes then then
yes yes yes it's a good question so okay
so way actually you know for a while we
were obsessed not only with a you know
we were really obsessed with two
messages right so we have four messages
do not have to want two messages and we
worked really hard and then a a you know
it turns out that in practice they a lot
of times they actually implement the the
complete you know interactive solution
that requires many many runs so it's a
good question I you know it depends I
I'm actually not an expert in practice
so I don't know you know when I talked
with a hunt woman he says that
non-attractive solutions are very very
important when I talk with other people
they say that no none who cares about
interaction time big deal so maybe
people who are more applied can so you
know it's it's it's very very efficient
they depend on the PCP you're using
but I think by now we have very
efficient PCP so it's it's a so I think
it's not the main thing is to implement
the PCP then the hard thing of the snog
implementation is the PCP I think most
of them I'm not sure but I think most of
the work there maybe someone can correct
me if I'm wrong properties you can do
that too
traditional PCP require individual
symbols are yet to be made more
practical so the quite inefficient in
practice and this will replace by linear
recipes all of the communes Wilson
actually all these recent line of words
who plays classical right exactly that's
so I think the main the main rotation in
the snog thing exactly the PCP coming up
with good PCBs so it's practical to send
the difference between the two right
away
so yes the thing on the bottom right
yeah completely more efficient than now
than just doing let them do it yeah this
is actually this work this work is not
the snark this is this does not rely on
PCP this isn't pre-processing it's
something else so this is not within
what they named and then you weren't
asking about this right snarks yeah
so a oh you call this a snog sorry okay
no no so hey I don't know Craig okay but
this world does not rely on PC because
it's in a pre-processing so maybe I'll
finish I want to mention some more work
and then you know I'll go so so okay I
think so yes I think I see I see I see
so when you've answered that the PC well
you use here is kind of a linear PCP
that mean it's it's what's the query
complexity of that PCP so you just
assume that the that that the shooting
card can only do linear computation
essentially that the cheating cloud can
only do linear most honest and the
cheating yeah and the cheating okay so
aim okay
so then there was a I didn't talk about
these would the world works and so this
work was doing pre-processing but then
there was a lot of work trying to get
rid of the pre-processing they were work
and trying to do it with extractable
ecology resistant hash function so this
is again a knowledge assumption and then
it was a really nice work of baton skien
friends that did it publicly verifiable
so to message publicly verifiable aim
and a but again he needed to assume
knowledge assumptions Oh what happened
to our one message deleted
oh you're right okay so when okay so but
okay so so what what do we have here so
we have for NP if you were some
knowledge you're golden okay you get
everything you want but you need to
assume knowledge what if we want to do
standard assumptions so I want to
mention what I'm going to focus on it's
a work with a one what woman with our
hands the way we do to message
delegation assuming computational appear
or again for this talk just think of fhe
but it's only for deterministic
computation so not envy okay and I won
so this is the focus but I want to
mention follow-up works after this so
there's a lot of nice work sorry for
making guys so small but there's just
too many of you to fit so there's really
nice work and getting
they do actually succeed garbling and in
particular they get public so this is
not publicly verifiable
they managed to get it publicly
verifiable and Rio or there's also
really nice work of oh man in guy North
Blum who do it under a specific multi
linear map assumption a kind of standard
as much as you can say standard to multi
linear apps but yeah you know no I don't
want to say that so yeah I let me just
say io knowledge of exponent falsifiable
assumption in multi linear maps
no good no bad no ugly okay so sorry I'm
gonna skip this this is the bar okay so
okay so back to Alan's question about
about practice so there's been a lot of
work practical work on this topic I'm
not an expert under and and you know
practical sign the practice practice
side of things but see so you have here
a Mariana you have Craig you have a lot
of people here you can ask
oh wow fish so you know ask ask your
friends but but let me just say one
thing let me just say one thing that's
you know amazed me that here is a quote
from one of the papers on the topic that
these yellow schemes are sufficiently
mature to deploy in real cloud computing
systems
but I can quote it has something to
quote yes don't say that okay
they have both there some they have both
dinner I mean they have a specific
instruction for specific functions and
then they have but it is not like that
quotation there's no pause okay let's
continue okay so this is the problem I'm
gonna focus on okay so a okay so we saw
with interactive proof there's so much
we can do okay we can't hope to get
general results from that we're stuck
with space we want general result so the
first idea you know let's go back to our
origins what other tools do we have to
play around with so the immediate
extension of interactive books is multi
proven attractive books so what are it's
an ocean by Benno cause that's like
Killian and Victor's on what is the
multi prove er it's the same thing but
now assume there are two boomers or more
than two provers okay and these pores
are there we have something do not
interact so before they can you know
talk they can decide on strategy but
once the proof starts they go to
different rooms the verifier send each
one a query gets a response and based on
that decides whether to accept or reject
so this is a proof model again the
motivation for this came from zero
knowledge their goal was to do stood to
information theoretic zero knowledge
which they did and not then talk about
zero knowledge here but then there was a
work by the by formula that showed a
remarkable result that any proof can be
made exponentially shorter if you only
had two non interactive provers in other
words suppose you wanted to prove some
statement that you needed to compute in
time T is huge okay all you needed the
amount of in the size of q1 and either
of the queries and the answers
is only poly logarithmic in T and even
the best ones are ended in marketing but
think of poly log
okay so exponentially shorter and here's
the precise statement any tea-time
computation has intractable here even
the Poobah runtime is efficient only
polynomial blow-up and this polynomial
can be made pretty close to T and the
verifiers runtime is great it's only
linear up to some poly log terms or or
you could put your old tilde of X and
the communication is also very small
great now maybe I'll stop here for a
second and tell you why why does they
have so much power these two
non-interactive provers what gives the
smanos power
intuitively the way to think of it think
of suspects okay someone can Emma
committed a crime if you have two
suspects you put them in different rooms
they can't communicate they can't cheat
you're very easily gonna catch them
because they don't know what they're
gonna be asked then you know you can if
you have only one suspect okay so that
kind of you know the intuition and
really that's how the proof works like a
bunch of consistency checks that's how
the proof of you
check him and then you consider the
second is he consistent if you
consistent it's really like suspects
okay and then I want to mention a really
nice work of formal wonpil in sensor
that they showed you know what if the
communication if the proof is so short
so short why not forget about the
provers ask each prover
to tell me his answer to each and every
query he may possibly ever be asked you
know if the proof is that the questions
are of size log you know think of lots
for second then the proof in size
polynomial so just write your answers to
each and every query the other prover
does the same Bumi I don't need you and
I'm just going to query this proof and a
few so I'm just gonna ask you know q1 q2
done and this gave rise to a really
really beautiful celebrated PCP theorem
that shows that actually any proof can
be converted to such a proof that
probabilistically checkable
okay so you can take a poof you can
convert to another proof I've almost the
same size so we're not out of work
trying to improve the parameters and by
now we know that any proof can be
converted into a probability checkable
one of essentially almost the same size
they can be verified actually by reading
only constant number of bits and you can
if you read three bits you can be
convinced with probability you know
seven eight that the proof is Crafton
and then you can repeat oh it's why am i
telling you so first it's beautiful why
not you know you should know about this
these results but how does it can we use
them so you know up here it seems well
you can't I don't I'm not giving you to
cloud so what is it help you that you
have to prove interact approves I've
only one cloud and for this BCP to be
useful you know they need to put this
huge PCP this PCP the fan of the proof
is at least the size of the original
proof it's big the computation so you
know we need some do you put a need to
put it somewhere and so and then you can
access it but what are you gonna put it
you don't trust the cloud so the count
where's the common I put it for you you
don't have the memory to store this
thing so it seems I priori maybe not
useful but it turns out it's very useful
so let me show you first the use of PCP
for delegation so this was first used by
Killian and I think a nice idea was your
script oh so again we're not trying to
hide but so crypto is very useful here
your script so how are we gonna use
crypto there it is the cloud is going to
compute this long PCP so he's gonna take
the computation he's gonna convert this
computation to a prolifically checkable
one okay so this is the PCP and then
he's gonna send the client the answer f
of X with a hash of this BCP now this
hash is a commitment binding okay so he
gave him think of it as a collision
resistant hash so now effectively
intuitively it's like putting this in
the sky somewhere you know this is the
first round and then the user can ask
the queries get back the answers and one
can prove that it sound and that
scallions work and actually all these
works are based on this paradigm you
commit to the PCP and
you ask queries so this one is
interactive this one uses random Oracle
to reduce the interaction and this uses
some you know more machinery to this
interaction using knowledge but but
that's essentially kind of the initial
idea behind these schemes questions
reduction for to clouds by asking one
cloud the same question in two different
ways very good question so I'm gonna get
to that that's great yes the answer is
yes and that I that's how that's okay so
thank you very much for the questions
the question was you know you have one
car can you somehow you want to have two
cars you have only one can you somehow
give the two queries tomorrow ask only
one cloud in some other way and the
answer is yes that's exactly what we're
gonna do okay so now I'm gonna show you
how to use kind of the the multi prove
our interactive proof to get delegation
okay and actually it will shown the next
our multi proven attractive proof and
PCBs are really the same so I showed you
how any multiple interactive proof kind
of can be our to prove interactive prove
moves and perverse is the same kind of
light leads to PCP PCP also leads to
multiple constructor spoofing I'm gonna
show you that in the next hour we're
gonna use that okay so now let me show
you the idea kind of that underlies
these work you know I'm so sad because
they're so beautiful ideas in the other
work that I really wanted to talk about
but I feel like there's just so much I
can bombard you with so I'm gonna focus
on this okay so the theorem I'm gonna
I'm going to focus on is the theorem
from the work with the van and a1 which
says that most women are not which says
that any deterministic time computation
this is only good for the turistic
computations it has a two message
delegation scheme assuming learning with
air the W assumption proven run time is
quadratic verify run time is quasi
linear and the communication is you know
depends only on the security parameter
I want to point out everywhere all my
wealth um our works where I set out w/e
I cheated sorry
almost lwe but not quite I needed lwe
with that sound that secure against
quasi-polynomial time adversary's and
actually it's a double cheat so with
with if if the language is polynomial
time than I need
just quasi poly security of course of
the language as exponential then it's
unavoidable you need exponential or
substantial security okay but for this
talk forget it because it's gonna be
high-level enough that you won't even
see maybe I'll mention where the quasi
poly comes in its security parameter
with a poly log what yeah so sorry that
poly log should have been Oh tailed of
one so you know this all thing that one
just hide the security parameter now
it's up to you you can take the security
round parameter to be poly log and then
this is great everything is very small
but you rely on harder and stronger
assumptions you can take the security
parameter to be bigger and then you rely
on better assumptions so I'm leaving it
vague okay exactly that's what I say for
if you want quasi poly hardness you need
the security parameter to be polynomial
II related to the time oh there's a lot
of other t8 is one but the main
difference is that the verify runtime is
it's for memory delegation the verify
this is what I'm showing now is not the
memory setting yeah but the other is a
ram thing if you want you can think of
it about the rams off in this heading
where you don't care about ram and the
input is small and you get improvement
even for this setting full you get rid
of the T Square DT
the Liberty star can be vd8 star can be
anything
yes it can be exactly it can be DDH star
it can be yeah yes yes yes
I need the apparently depend on the
security parameter it's the same same
thing yeah this is for chewing machines
the RAM we had similar results for M
that I'm going to show later but for now
I'm going to focus on the Turing machine
results I always modeled to machine I
never go to circuits but certain machine
circuits are very similar the RAM is
kind of the difference in the RAM is
that you know you have random access to
the memory the memory can be huge and
the verifier doesn't even look at the
mem at the X he gives away the X ahead
of time in the cloud can do computations
on this X and the verifier runs in time
you know that doesn't even depend on the
X but that's all gonna save that to the
end that was just a teaser kind of okay
so let me give you the outline of how we
get this so the starting point is the
multi prover we have multi proofer let's
already use this but unfortunately we
have many but we have only one cloud so
what are we gonna do we're gonna follow
a really nice approach of again without
that suggest for us a way to simulate
many pools are you using just one prover
so this is kind of a way to heuristic to
to do delegation unfortunately this
heuristic as if does not work and that
was pointed out by a very nice paper of
Boca tile the which they found some
subtle bug with this approach and what
we do we show that actually you you can
get around this bug if you use multi
proven tractor poop that have stronger
soundness so what is the stronger
soundness if it's secure not only
against local cheating provers that just
you know we said that cheating provers
are in different rooms they can they
can't interact each cheating prove
erects locally based on his own query
that's the model nothing well if I'm
also secure against
no cheating provers that are not quite
local but are still know signaling which
I explained what that is if I have that
then I can simulate that to get one
prove er so if I start with that I might
be that secure against stronger
adversary's not only local adversary's
but slightly stronger adversary's then
we get I can similar to Singapore
networks so I'm going to explain what
this no signaling strategy is this is
Einstein it's a way it's inspired by him
I even have him as a how many people
here have citation you know cite
Einstein in their work oh I'm impressed
Oh your favorite face
okay so how do I go from two foresters
in approver this is the idea you know
the first idea is well you only want
poober sending the two queries send us a
improve or the two queries get back the
answers well let's do that this is
really not sound okay because think
again of the two suspects if you give
the same suspect the two queries c'mon
you know he can clearly cheat so the
idea of the yellow tile paper was give
it to them encrypted and encrypt each
query under a totally fresh independent
public key
okay so encrypt put this one in one box
with one public key but this lock the
other query in another box with another
public key and send it to the cloud now
this is an RPG of course they didn't
have a Fiji then it was before Craig was
born so they had to use that
computational theory but we'll talk
we'll give the notation of fhe since
you're all familiar with that notation
so so intuitively why does this work
well the Pooh ver when he sees when he
finds if you think of shines gloves when
you try to enter Q 1 when you manipulate
Q 1 you will secure so you know I want
is only function of Q 1 when you
manipulate Q 2 you're only a function of
Q 2 so I think like it should work this
should be found
okay so let me try to prove it to you
actually let's do the proof okay how do
we prove security in our soundness in
crypto by reduction so suppose we have a
cheating ah a cheater cheater here that
cheats cheating prove er what are we go
so what can he do he cheats two options
either his answer
one is indeed only a function of the
first query an answer to the only
function of the second query may be
cheats this way in which case well you
broke the multi proven tractive proof
you camp this you can cheat like this
okay so that's one case another case so
I had no idea how this adversity works
I'd want to so anything about the
adversary' okay he may be inefficient I
don't know what he does okay but either
he act locally on each query so anyone
is a local it only depends on it q1 it
was only depend on Q to in which case
you can use that to break this scheme
because you can behave like this adverse
or in this scheme and break the security
of the MIP case - what if he's now local
what is that how we manage it I don't
allow somehow he manages to give an
answer that depends on both queries in
this case I want to say well your books
are encryption scheme because if you
know you can so how do you break the
encryption scheme you open only this
lock you don't at all and now you learn
something about q1 okay because a
towards the function of q1 so you want
something about q1 done proof there's a
bug anybody see the bug it's a subtle
bug they were Cynthia she's not here to
tell us about the bug so you have to
come up she's not here to help you okay
I'll show you this bug so the bug is
what they notice there's a third case
what is the third case what if a2 is a
function of both queries but it's a
randomized function it's a randomized
function so that a - as a function it
really depends on both but the
distribution if you think about is a
distribution it doesn't depend on the
other query so the distribution of a2 is
the same no matter what q1 is there as a
function it's a function of both and
this kind of strategy is called no
signaling that essentially means that a
- it has the same distribution no matter
what q1 is so it doesn't signal
information about q1 you can look at it
and say oh now I know what you want
isn't there for break the encryption
it doesn't signal information but it's
still not local because it depends on
both now at this point you can say well
how is this useful can you really cheat
in this way
how can an adversary cheat by using I
mean okay if you know partner speaking
only depends on q1 q2 I mean look it
it's the same distribution no matter
what you wanted the same distribution so
why would I help him cheat so let me
show you
actually but these type of strategies
are very powerful they can help the
nursery cheat and let me give you it by
an example
so there are a very simple to prove
interactive proof for the three coloring
language okay what's the so the proven
want to prove that this graph is 3
colorable the to prove is that's what
they need to prove to the verifier how
does the verifier check this it gives
them two vertices two random vertices
that are either adjacent or the same any
expect to get colors two colors if the
colors if the vertices were the same and
the colors are the same he accepts if
the vertices are the car adjacent he
accepts only if the colors are different
so it's a very poor soundness condition
but still you if the graph is not 3
colorable you can't always cheat that's
for sure there's no way that these two
approvers were all will succeed in
cheating with probability 1 now I'm
going to show you how it a no signalling
Hoover can always treat with probability
1 how here's what he does a randomized
strategy if the vertices are are
different
he gives distinct random colors if
they're the same he gets the same random
color you always accept him always and
now note if you look at one color the
distribution is random doesn't matter of
the other vertices same virtus or it's a
neighboring vertex the distribution of
of each color here is completely random
he doesn't give you this if you see this
color it doesn't give you any
information about the other vertex
whether it's the same vertex or
neighboring burn discs so what if our
adverse are here no do what delegate
just came out of it and this is how this
works very magically cheated how are you
gonna use them to break so you can't use
them to break you know the multi proven
tractors prove because he's not local
but you also can't use them to break
their fakie scheme
this is not a strategy that he can he
can apply on on a kitschy scheme right
because we need to compare what I don't
know how we can do it but I don't know
how to prove that he cannot do it it's a
problem of the proof yes the profiles in
the Rye encryption scheme for which you
can implement actually no signaling
strategy
I mean without break it can be either
like an Apache scheme for which you can
actually implement or no signal isn't
there a good question I don't know the
answer to that I don't know I don't
there's a good question to come up with
a fakie scheme that sick that's
resilient to such a such a thing okay so
when let me think if we okay let me just
so so what we do but if so let me just
finish this if we had an MIB that is
secure against such no signaling
strategies so we do we think you suppose
I had an MIT that I know you cannot
cheat with these strategies then we're
golden we're done why if you had a
cheating prove oh here look two options
either he's signaling or he's no
signaling it is no signaling you can use
them to break they might because this a
might be secure if we assume that it's
secure gets all signaling if it is
secure though something we're done case
to this adverse we actually signals
information if it signals information
you can use them to break the fhe you
know look at it - it actually gives
information [ __ ] you one so you use this
information to break the fhe that's the
high level idea let me just mention what
I'm hiding okay so what do you mean
break for signal you need to signal if
enough information not enough the signal
negligible round of information so it's
not enough to just have signal need to
have like some Delta signaling you know
you signal some Delta amount of
information so this is not as as true as
I'm hiding here this kind of factors and
also I said the quasi poly thing where
does that come up it comes up because
when you signal information not gonna
sell you signal it efficiently
so the distinguish here
is not necessarily efficient so that's
where you need the quasi poly instead of
the poly but I'm hiding this under the
rug this is the high-level idea okay QED
so what remains is to construct this no
signaling MIP and what we're going to do
in the next hour is first I'm going to
show you what is what I showed you the
picture of Einstein because I like it
but it's actually connected to physics
this notion of no signaling so I'm going
to show you the connection to physics
and then I'm going to show you talk a
little bit of the construction how to
construct this no signaling multi probe
interactive booths